so we've had this ongoing debate right
nature versus nurture that asks the
question are we pre-written beings are
we pre determined beings do our genetics
dictate our fate right or are we made by
our environment are we molded by our
experience does language structure how
we see the world does culture dictate
who we become are we molded and shaped
by the unfolding dynamics of interfacing
with our environment yes this is
sometimes known as epigenetics how
literally things that happen to you
during your formative years can
transform how your genetic structure is
expressed experience can change biology
okay but recently this debate has taken
on a new heights because some of the new
science there's an article called the
social life of genes we've talked about
this which said that the idea of
epigenetics actually goes much farther
and that experienced throughout our
lives affects our genetic expression and
the doctor the researcher quoted in the
piece actually had the best way to
describe it he basically says that our
self compose our bodies are a technology
for turning experience into biology that
even the cognitive dreaming that we give
to an experience
the physical expression of our cellular
biology so that consciousness itself
interpretation storytelling and framing
how we give meaning to our lives can
actually have a real effect and our
genetic level at the way our genetic
software expresses itself via and we've
always heard the bumper stickers that
talk about the power of the mind of
power positive thinking to the fact that
we can shape our reality but this notion
not just affects genetic expression at
one point in your life but through while
your life means that you're constantly
composing your own biological unfolding
I designed therefore I've become I've
said it before I'll say it again but we
are as God's my friends and we might as
well get good at it
you